I'm going it doesn't pass a sniff test
because either way it's a moment of
silence do you yell praise Jesus praise
Jesus praise Jesus during remember and
stay silence because I told you to shut
up look a moment of silence is not that
complicated to figure out then it
becomes an intellect problem so glad to
have this next guest now a lot of the
guests they have in the program I'm
personal friends with or I know full
disclosure I haven't spent a ton of time
on this gentleman we've talked about him
a lot he's running for president there's
nothing else to say Ted Cruz org senator
Ted Cruz thank you for coming on good
sir Stephen thank you for having me good
to be with you well I'm glad I'm glad to
have you on and note I don't think this
is that I think this is the first time
I've seen you without a full suit and
tie going on oh that's why I just made
it home so I lost lost the jacket and
tie and much much happier that way well
good because our demo are there a bunch
of basement-dwelling miscreants who are
29 year old males and they'll want to
feel more laid back all right listen I
would be better off if I was wearing my
Van Halen concert shirt
if you have one I would have advised it
absolutely listen if we have you back
and you wear that that it doesn't matter
what you talk about regarding policy
that will be the comments section I will
tell you this I didn't actually see Van
Halen in concert but but I do have
somewhere a Pink Floyd concert shirt
because I saw a Pink Floyd in 1988 in
the Astrodome Wow
I am NOT a Pink Floyd fan this has
started a horrendous that's all right I
like some of their music my thing is
it's kind of the same thing with our
generation I would say the mars volta
where music can be great and then
there's a certain amount of point
there's a certain point where becomes
pretentious just let's just put in a
bunch of noise and I'm no longer paying
attention but I will say it was unusual
to see a gigantic pink pig floating
balloon in the Astrodome that that was
more than a little difference I can't
imagine so well that brings us to I just
forgot the gentleman's name um gosh the
Pink Floyd guy just did that film of the
wall I always forget his name Jared can
you help me here anyway he just came out
and did this whole thing with with
Israel you know that no one should go
and perform in Israel and I
Roger Waters Roger Waters sorry there
you go that's how dumb I am a senator is
correcting me on my rock history this is
a so he says you know no one should
perform in Israel I'm sure you've you've
kept on top of this right now
you just issued a challenge to Barack
Obama and this administration I'm full
for context they called you offensive
they basically called you out as well as
Christians because of their position on
Syrian refugees so you go ahead the
floor is yours sir well you know
yesterday and today President Obama has
now two days in a row attacked me
directly did first from from Turkey and
then then today from from Manila
yesterday he attacked me said I was
unamerican today he attacked me and said
I was offensive all because I'm saying
what millions of Americans are saying
across this country which is that we
disagree with Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton's plan to bring to America tens
of thousands of Syrian Muslim refugees I
think it is lunacy when this
administration can't vet them has no
idea who among them maybe Isis
terrorists but because of political
correctness they want to bring him bring
them here in any way and President Obama
says those of us that want to keep this
country safe and keep Isis terrorists
out we are offensive and we're
unamerican it really is remarkable it is
remarkable
have you you know I know Barack Obama
President Obama's not a big fan of you
have you spent us an implement of time
with him personally is he know it's very
little I mean I've met him at a few
events and and he's he's a little bit
aloof and standoffish but I'll tell you
my response today I said look if he's
gonna two days in a row attack me now
it's a little rich to call me unamerican
as he's standing on foreign soil but I
said listen if you want to insult me
insult me to my face right I said why
don't we had let's have a one-on-one
debate anywhere you like my one
preference I'd like to do it in the
United States of America not in some
country overseas but a one-on-one debate
on his Syrian Muslim policy a one-on-one
debate on his foreign policy that's been
a disaster and if he's so confident
and you know today also he was lecturing
all the Republicans saying we're scared
of the media which is more than a little
hypocritical given that he's usually
surrounded by sycophants aying how wise
he is because he never wants any real
questions and banned FoxNews for a while
I you know it'd be funny if it weren't
lives you know at stake right now that's
exactly right
um it's kind of jarred I'm getting a
little bit of reverb Pearson obi-wan
I've toned that down but one thing I
will say it reminded me of dream day
where they recorded American Idiot and
they recorded it in England and I got
into a servile War of the words but the
killers I think was Brandon Flowers he
said listen I don't you have your right
to express the opinion but you have a
bunch of English people shouting yeah
American Idiot and that's just cowardly
and and that's a big thing character is
an issue here but here's something I
want to add you know Jared and I've
talked about this now you're you're
obviously deeply Christian I don't feel
I'm mischaracterizing you I don't want
to put words in your mouth but you've
not necessarily been seen as a we've had
governor Huckabee on may be a social
conservative as though that's your main
cause you're seen as a constitutionalist
how do you sometimes you do have to go
well yeah the Christian thing to do
obviously is be sympathetic of course
that's not a way of policy sometimes you
do have to put your Christian hat on and
sometimes your American hat on and with
national security right now how do you
balance the two well listen my faith is
the most important thing and Who I am
and all of us the American people we're
compassionate people we always have been
if you look at these refugees I mean it
is a humanitarian crisis and it's a
crisis caused by the utter failures of
the obama-clinton foreign policy but you
know the director of the FBI told
Congress that that we cannot vet these
Syrian Muslim refugees because they said
listen if we get information on them we
query the database we have nothing in
the database we have no ability what we
could as he put it query til the cows
come home but we don't have any
information on who the Isis terrorists
are so there's nothing to check the
administration cannot determine who is
and is not an Isis terrorist right and
and so listen many of these refugees are
legitimately fleeing persecution but
they should be resettled in Middle
Eastern
countries that are majority Muslim and
and we can help with that right but but
but the first obligation of the
president the first obligation of the
commander-in-chief should be to protect
the safety and security of the United
States of America and if you look at the
the refugee wave that's going into
Europe one estimate was that that wave
consisted of 77% young males that is an
odd demographic for a refugee wave we
know at least one of the terrorists in
Paris was among those refugees right and
it doesn't make any sense at all for
President Obama and Hillary Clinton to
be bringing in tens of thousands of
Syrian Muslim refugees when Isis has
said they intend to carry out terrorist
attacks just like Paris here in the
United States and to murder hundreds or
if they can thousands of Americans we
should protect America first now I agree
with you and I was talking about this
today did you see the the turkey the
soccer game the Turkish fans do you see
that baby not okay well let me kind of
give you a briefing here by the way
Stephen you'll like this but you know
links to your show light up my Facebook
page don't admit that don't admit that
folks on my stream are big I click on
things all the time
well well today actually we just had a
violation of service on Facebook they
said well I said well okay hold on a
second
tell me which post I didn't tell me
which post and they didn't tell me which
policy listen I mean you know listen but
that's why I say be careful because
we're pretty edgy I'm a an entertainer
and I'm always very straightforward that
we're not profane but we do some very
offensive things so people know that
going in and Facebook had a problem with
that we've had denial of service tactics
on the sites you know angry I mean right
next on care on next to Salman Rushdie
and mark Stein and what people don't and
this is actually ties back to the point
about Turkey people think oh you're on
care we'll have they blowing you up yet
well no but we have had all kinds of
cyber attacks they've tried to take down
the site they have successfully a couple
times YouTube Facebook so Turkey there
was a moment of silence who was Turkey
playing do we know Jerry was a group I'm
trying to I don't know one of
I can't stand soccer men and pink
jerseys with buns in their hair and
hockey guy as though they had a moment
of silence and they were yelling out
what definitely sounded like booze and
Allah ho Akbar and to the point you can
see the player reactions where they're
shocked
now the left has tried to spin it saying
they were actually shouting out martyrs
never die and there's two theories one
was for the victims but the one they say
is they were actually mad because there
was no moment of silence for the victims
in Turkey from an attack I'm going it
doesn't pass a sniff test because either
way it's a moment of silence do you yell
praise Jesus praise Jesus praise Jesus
during remember and stay silence because
I tell you to shut up
look a moment of silence is not that
complicated to figure out well then it
becomes an intellect problem but that's
the best case scenario you know let's
talk Turkey has been widely regarded as
one of the most moderate Islamic
countries what would you I mean what
would we put there Turkey Malaysia UAE
I don't want to speak out of turn you
would know better than I would so what
would you would you could put until
recently would we have put turkey in
that list would that have been fair from
what is relatively speaking I mean look
at it has not had the same problems as
places like Libya and Somalia or Yemen
but but but air21 is a pretty vocal and
aggressive Islamist yes now and I'm not
saying you would but I'm saying leftists
touted as kind of look at leftist left
this whitewash what's happening in
Turkey quite a bit right so that's the
best case scenario so let's take
terrorism extreme best case scenario you
still have people who in Europe want to
implement Sharia law and install Sharia
Courts yeah you know Ben Carson dr. ben
Carson got a lot of flack for saying
Sharia law is basically incompatible
with the Constitution it's not
politically incorrect
is it accurate it's absolutely I mean
listen I had been fighting against
Sharia law for many many years under our
Constitution it is only American law
that is enforced in our courts and
Sharia law has no place and if you look
at you know the consistent pattern of
both Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton is
that they refuse to acknowledge
radical Islamic terrorism they refused
to say the words we saw Hillary Clinton
in the debate this weekend she would not
say radical Islamic terrorism and you
cannot defeat it if you're not even
willing to say its name and this infects
every mistake they make on foreign
policy you know because they don't
identify who the enemy is
the reason Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton want to bring in all these
Syrian Muslims is because they don't
recognize that radical Islamic terrorism
Islamists embrace a theocratic and
political philosophy that they should
murder or first forcibly convert anyone
they view as an infidel what they're
doing to Christians they're engaged in
genocide they're they're crucifying them
they're they're beheading them and yet
this president acts as an apologist
right for radical Islamic terrorists
well my point is even not radical
Islamic terrorists you scale it back
moderate Islam is still pretty bad if
you're a feminist if you're gay if you
want to talk about equal rights it's
still not very good I'm not saying
Muslims can't be good people just like
any group can be consists of good people
but if you look at any like I'm saying
moderate Islamic countries there are not
bastions of human rights disregarding
terrorism look more than once when I've
had conversations with with with
leftists I've asked them you know you
know when they're when they're focused
on on issues like gay marriage and how
it's the most important issue from their
perspective I've asked I've said you
know recent years have been very bad
years for gay rights because Isis is
murdering homosexuals Iran is murdering
homosexuals Barack Obama sending a
hundred billion dollars to the ayatollah
khomeini empowers a radical Islamist
leader who wants to kill us who chants
death to America and and and and the
funny thing is leftist apparently have
no trouble with sending a hundred
billion dollars to someone who murders
homosexuals right what do you do when
they say their commitment to to ignoring
the evil of the Islamist is so great
that everything else fades in front of
okay we have to go to break
quickly so let me give you last word
before we go to the break we'll come
back what do you say when left to say
well George Bush was in some pretty cozy
relationships with people who were less
than Pro civil rights in the Islamic
world because Republicans have been
guilty of that too how do you respond to
that
well I think what should guide US
foreign policy is the vital national
security interest of this country and
and you're right
not every ally of this country has an
unblemished record on human rights and
we should speak out against it if
they're not honoring human rights we
should speak out against one moment hold
that thought louder with crowd or Ted
Cruz org stay tuned senator Ted Cruz
running for president he is back I'm
sorry I had to cut you off our evil
corporate overlords continue to thought
did you just just be sure to send send a
portion of the revenue to Ted Cruz dad
or I well I'll put it through my PAC -
you're my pack we'll speak with your PAC
and then I'll call big unions and have
them give to Bernie Sanders PAC and then
only on the condition that he says he
hasn't gotten any special interest money
please continue well you know we were
talking about foreign policy being
focusing on the u.s. national security
interest if you look at the
obama-clinton foreign policy the one
place they've been eager to use military
force is inexplicably where it benefits
radical Islamic terrorism so for example
in Libya Hillary Clinton's war in Libya
where Obama and Hillary led NATO in
attacking Qaddafi now listen Qaddafi was
a bad guy hid a horrible human rights
record but the sanctions against Libya
the strong foreign policy of this
country had worked Qaddafi had handed
over his entire nuclear program he was
cooperating with America against radical
Islamic terrorists he was handing over
terrorists to this country was an ally
in stopping radical Islamic terrorists
in northern Africa mm-hmm but yet
President Obama and Hillary Clinton led
the NATO effort to bomb him to topple
him to kill him ultimately and the
result is they handed Libya over to
radical Islamic terrorism you want to
know why Benghazi happened four people
were murdered it wasn't just Hillary
Clinton's malfeasance of that night it
was the failed foreign policy that had
turned Libya into a
an Islamist war I have I'm sorry no
softballs here yeah it was a YouTube
video get it correct senator get your
facts correct when I first read bad the
interesting thing is Hillary at the same
time told Chelsea her daughter she knew
it was terrorism so while she's lying to
the American people she's emailing
Chelsea going oh it's terrorism then she
turns to the American people and says
it's this still a YouTube video right
well I've talked about that when I first
read that I've done quite a few videos
on Islam when I first read it and they
said you know it's pop you know I've had
videos with many millions of plays on
Islam I thought oh no my video just got
Americans killed and then I saw it now
it's gonna video have like a couple
hundred plays no one had even seen it
you know is one of those things that's
totally irrelevant
anyways that's got well I want to go a
little Matt and Steve and Steven Lee
make a quick point on that it's not just
Libya we see the same thing with Egypt
where the obama-clinton foreign policy
toppled Mubarak now look Mubarak had a
sketchy human rights record as well it
was it he had real issues there but he
had been a consistent ally of America
for decades they toppled Mubarak and
they put the Muslim Brotherhood in power
which is a terrorist organization
funding terrorists that are trying to
murder Americans and you look at Syria
now they're trying to topple Assad if
Assad Falls Syria will fall entirely in
the control of radical Islamic
terrorists and why is it that this
administration the only time they use
military force is to undermine American
allies and and and to further their
efforts consistently further a radical
Islamic terrorism and I think it's
because they refuse to even acknowledge
it exists so they don't ask the
difficult questions about who are the
bad guys were benefit well listen
senator I don't mean to say that you're
you're out of touch because you're doing
with it politically but we're talking
about a generation of people who get
offended if you use the genetically
proper pronouns so getting to the point
of calling something Islamic terrorism
is a little further down the trail these
guys are so nutty that the federal
government is going after school
districts trying to force them to let
boys shower with little girls now let
and I'm the father of two daughters and
the idea that the federal government is
coming in saying that boys with all the
the god-given equipment that a boys can
be in the shower room with junior high
girls this is lunacy and I bet you
they're a whole lot of parents
particularly parents of daughters
they're not not eager to have the
federal government saying guess what
your daughter has to shower with with a
boy if he wants to be in there yeah I
know and that's you know leftist
simplify it to love versus hate and
we're gonna hold on a second here this
is an issue that has gone on for all of
time the the gender differences which
now we have to act as though it doesn't
exist and there's intersectional
feminism I mean I don't want to get off
too too far off in luige but I will say
this if I am a Republican candidate I'm
just a younger guy we have a much
younger demo I mean there is an even
second place in the conservative sphere
with people as young as us and I
actually when I get to something that I
think would be important for you and
connecting with them but there are four
winning issues for Republicans free
speech that's a winning issue the
pendulum shifted yeah guns that's a
winning issue and then Islam now is a
winning issue calling it out for what it
is and fun life also anti third-wave
intersectional is feminism there's been
a huge turn from both men and women
those are winning issues yet regardless
of your personal faith and people will
get on board sometimes I watch the
debates and Republicans just seem to
miss it and they focus on issues that
are losing issues what why why is that
well look I can't speak to other
Republican sure what I can speak to are
the issues I care about and and I have
been passionate about defending the
Constitution and Bill of Rights my
entire life I mean literally from when I
was a teenager and and you're right free
speech Democrats don't believe in free
speech anymore you know I wrote a book
this summer called a time for truth and
I described in that book the Democrats
efforts to repeal the free speech
protections in the First Amendment and I
led the fight against that in the Senate
is the thing that probably horrified me
the most about the Harry Reid Senate and
when it came up for a vote do you know
how many Senate Democrats voted to
preserve the first amendment in the Bill
of Rights I'm gonna go with
- how hard was that a trot a single one
zero every Democrat was on the other
side and and I'll tell you I gave a
speech on the Senate floor next to next
to a poster of Ted Kennedy who when
Democrats tried this 15-20 years ago
said we have an amended the Bill of
Rights in over 200 years now there's no
time to start and I said are there no
liberals left in the Democratic Party
are there no Ted Kennedy's right is no
one willing to defend the First
Amendment and sadly the modern
Democratic Party they are the party of
government power if a young person wants
to understand the Democrats if you think
the government should have power over
you to silence your speech to take away
your guns to invade your privacy to
control your life to raise your
healthcare bills to raise your
electricity bills to decide what you can
do with your life then you vote Democrat
if you believe in it individual liberty
then don't vote Democrats friends don't
let friends vote Democrat this is true i
well we we have 30 seconds so here's
what I want to do I want to continue on
that because as we go to the web
extended version for people listening to
rest early that's where you get you get
off of the weeds with with the youngins
and I want to follow on that path
because there are there are definitely
some things that I think you're catching
that maybe some other Republicans are
missing louder with crowder stay tuned
Ted Cruz dot-org he's getting a nice big
check from my pack to his good a lot of
credit calm for the web extended version
and we're off okay so this is not that
you need to be uncensored you're not
you're not a profane gentleman but you
don't need to worry about people issuing
trigger warnings so you're talking about
all the things you made are valid points
but then a lot of Millennials you lose
them the libertarians because of social
issues and they go well if that's true
you Republicans want to be in their
bedrooms what do you say to those young
Republicans want to tell me what I can
and can't smoke what do you say to them
well you know I actually think
federalism answers a lot of those
questions so you know you mentioned for
example drug legalization listen I
personally don't support legalizing
marijuana but I think under the
Constitution that's a question for the
states and I think individual states can
decide it differently I would vote
against it in Texas Texas had it as a
referendum but you know we've seen now
some states Colorado Washington state
they voted to do it and I will say one
of the real advantages of a federalist
system where different states can do
different things experiment we don't we
don't have to debate in the abstract and
theoretical what will happen with pot
legalization I can tell you this if
Colorado over the next few years we see
teen drug use skyrocketing if we start
seeing crime rates go up we start seeing
serious problems in that jurisdiction my
guess is other states will be less eager
to go down the road but we don't have to
experiment with the whole country we can
let the people of one state decide the
public policy that makes sense for that
you know and that's been my position and
people get really mad some of the
libertarians hold on a second I said I
don't believe in a federal Department of
Education but I believe states have the
right to create public schools and they
did for a long time so states have the
right to create their own divorce laws
yeah all right well I think that's a
reasonable answer okay no one gets away
without it so this is the one thing I
want since you're challenging Barack
Obama to talk to your face I've been
very pro Cruz in the show but I've also
been somewhat critical and here's here's
lemme frame this for you start with a
compliment I always say listen Ted Cruz
is probably sorry senator Ted Cruz is
probably the best person on his feet the
most prepared as a matter of fact I was
on a popular podcast and I still have
Republicans the party of intellectuals
how do you explain Ted Cruz I said well
what do you mean how do you explain Ted
Cruz and they were dumbfounded they had
no idea as to your credentials so that
yes and I've watched you speak and I say
he can go off-book but the big criticism
from even young conservatives is because
of the measured way in which you speak
sometimes it comes across as the
opposite it comes across premeditated or
maybe canned now has your team been
honest with you about this it's not a
policy thing it's not a principle thing
it's a presentation thing and are you
taking any steps to maybe because this
has been great you're talking van Halen
I feel like I'm seeing a side to senator
Cruz I've not seen before well this is
something we do a lot I mean one of the
things to keep in mind is that is the
whole mess of politics goes usually
through the filter of the media right
mr. CISO the media shows this tiny
little window of what they want to show
now you've had the debates but the
debates are pretty constrained to if
you've got 60 seconds to get a point
and you've got you know the first couple
of debates the moderators didn't want to
let me talk I got very few very little
time in the debates and just had a
couple of little 60 60 second vignettes
you look at the third and fourth debates
I decide all right enough of this
business I'm jumping in and and saying
what I want to say and and you know you
think of the third debate where you know
I listened to the ridiculous model
blasting everyone very huge and and it's
interesting it changed that debate you
saw the Republicans come together and
really follow that lead and you look at
the last debate the Fox Business debate
they did a fabulous job
and the moderators actually asked a real
substantive question we have we had
disagreements on policy but it wasn't a
question you know you say you don't like
that person's face I mean I wasn't
stupid insult okay let's see frankly I
think Carly has a beautiful face I love
a face okay
they called me the face loving but she'd
he's not coming on the show to in terms
of just if you put it be it unscripted
everywhere as I travel on the road I do
town halls everywhere why just do QA and
answer whatever on earth people want and
then so this is me the media doesn't
want to show it they want to paint the
media always wants to paint Republicans
is either stupid or evil right
ah and I guess for me I'm somewhat
encouraged they invented a third
category for me which is crazy I guess
yeah I would yeah they would say crazier
than depending on the story they'll just
throw in stupid or evil but that
actually brings me to something that
Jade we have the video forum this is
something that again well I had to throw
a harder question I just I love this
this is you who and the president of the
Sierra Club let me just show a few
minutes for people watching who won't
believe that this exists and I'm going
to roll this clip I'm curious yeah so
it's I want to understand this I do find
it highly interesting that the president
the Sierra Club when when asked what the
satellite data demonstrate
about warming apparently as is relying
on staff so so can you hear this clip
later yeah alright I want to show the
one thing sorry I missed it right before
I love for people who missed it there
you go there's that image Jerrod get
that up on the screen
it's the priceless image of him leaning
back and this is there you go so this is
my point when I wrote about it and not a
lot of people carried this there's not a
lot of plays on it he would say we
relied in the consensus of scientists
you ask him a question he goes well I'm
gonna rely on the consensus I'm sitting
on hold on a second if the president of
this year club one of the most
profitable influential environmental
impact lobbyist groups whatever category
is has to do this what's that
where's the consensus leaning I don't
know ask the president of Sierra Club
were you aware in that moment the BS
sorry that was happening I was
astonished at at just how little facts
or science or data and you look at at
essentially the global warming alarmists
right and and they're not engaged in
science i am the the son of two
mathematicians and computer programmers
and scientists i believe in science and
data but i think public policy should
actually follow the science and data so
the question that I was asking the
president Sierra Club is how do you
explain the fact that the computer
models that you're relying on show that
the earth should be warming dramatically
and he actually testified the earth is
cooking that was his term yes and I said
well how do you explain the fact that
the satellites that actually measure the
temperature show that there has been no
significant warming whatsoever for the
last 18 years the pause yeah and he was
unaware of the term which is a very
common term he had no idea what it was
it's like me going say to the Prince
Sierra Club have you heard of a bill I
mean it's kind of right under his
purview well and a little bit later in
that hearing the the ranking Democrat
Senator Costa stepped in and said well
it's unfair to
Kim these questions about because that
wasn't the topic of his testimony and
actually respondent said no wait a
second his written and oral testimony
was all about global warming I asked him
what do you do about the fact that the
evidence doesn't back up global warming
and he has no idea what he's talking
about well neither do you because it's
climate change senator I hate to have to
keep correcting you it's no longer
global warming its climate change
because it's not and actually Stephen
let me take that point to step back for
a second I think it's a good thing you
got a lot of younger listeners and not
all of them may have studied the facts
on this but a little bit of historical
context puts this whole debate in a very
different view so 30 40 years ago a
bunch of left-leaning politicians and
scientists told everyone we were having
global cooling that we were headed to
another Ice Age and their solution to
this was a massive government takeover
of the economy the energy sector in our
lives but then the evidence didn't back
it up it turned out the earth was not
cooling then a few years later these
same liberal politicians and a lot of
these same scientists came back and said
no no no actually the earth is warming
we have global warming mind you the
exact opposite of what they just said a
few years earlier right and the solution
was massive government control of the
economy the energy sector in every
aspect of our lives then fast forward to
the past couple of years we went through
18 years with no significant warming
whatsoever the evidence doesn't back it
up and then as you noted the theory
magically transmogrifies and it becomes
climate change now climate change for
ace for a politician who wants power
over your life is the perfect pseudo
scientific theory because it can never
be disproven if it gets hotter a colder
wetter or drier whatever happens the
magic theory is always right and
interestingly enough their solution is
exactly the same as global cooling and
global warming
it is massive government power over you
and me and everybody else and you start
to think maybe Al Gore and the rest of
these guys just want more and more power
and it's what we said earlier in the
show you want to understand Democrats
they're all about
government power over you and me and the
individual well I'm not a conspiracy
theorist I'm quite confident Al Gore is
dead after the antarctic sheet was
proven to be growing we had no one's
seen him since um you know it's you say
that because a big thing to a lot of
because the paleo movement and a lot of
these younger people they're very you
know since the science on diet directly
affects them they're very abreast of
this and so they go well hold on a
second the same people who pushed
against saturated fats where this with
neo vegetarian sort of lobby and they
pushed for basically you know artificial
vegetable oils and trans fats so now
they're pushing against trans fats and
we've changed our stance I think but was
it the FDA change their stance on eggs
and butter in moderation yeah so these
same people will talk about that and
recognize the same group the hypocrisy
that switched yet still think well
you're just a climate denier if it comes
to climate change and it's it's a weird
time same thing you know you're you and
I are declared science and I are that
the men and women are biologically
different and that the the ice sheet is
growing you know the funny thing is my
five-year-old knows there's a difference
between boys and girls and yet modern
leftist can't figure that out and and
you know going back to the global
warming debate climate change it is not
science its religion and one of the ways
you know it look at the language denier
that's the language of theology that is
heretic right any good scientist should
be a denier
the scientific method when you and I
learned in in biology class in high
school we should start with a hypothesis
and then you use evidence to disprove it
that's the scientific method and yet the
global warming alarmists they don't the
evidence is a problem for them so they
just say anyone that disagrees with my
decree i must have power over your life
you are a denier right that's not
science well and what's funny too is you
could even be lets say a climate you
acknowledge climate change you could
even maybe say okay we believe humans
are the cause of it you could maybe even
go down the trail and say even though
none of it has happened yet we believe
catastrophic results maybe you can even
go as far as Bernie Sanders and say Isis
as a result of climate change maybe and
still not
believe that the United States
government can fix it
you have to believe all those things to
believe the president of the Sierra Club
who's going ahead what are my facts
give me the spreadsheet so I meant by
the way at that same hearing was the
president of the u.s. black Chamber of
Commerce that said for example the Obama
administration's new global warming
rules would cost over 19 million
minority jobs 7 million African
Americans would lose their jobs and 12
million Hispanics would lose their jobs
so you need to understand when these
zealots want power they want power over
your life they're trying to take away
your job and they're trying to jack up
your electricity bill if you're a single
mom trying to make ends meet the last
thing you need is your electricity bill
doubling sure and yet these zealots want
power over your life I'm I'm much rather
fight for working men and women than for
Washington to have power over us
absolutely and you take it one step
further at the Cancun climate summit
where I went
Ted Kennedy not Ted Kennedy Ted Turner
advocated China's one-child pop
Siri is if Communist China tried it
let's maybe look and look toward another
path all right let's be honest you're in
Cancun you're not a climate something
well come on now come on Copenhagen was
before that yeah all right but you know
it's funny because yeah we're Americans
don't scale that back right I'm kind of
I always say let's go to the extreme and
then scale it back so you have it that's
the worst for Americans you double an
energy bill for someone in Mexico who's
not in Cancun they die they can't afford
to heat their food they can't afford you
know that's what people donors for third
you're basically issuing a death
sentence for third world countries and
that's the whole thing we get into a
whole bunch but I know you have to go
senator one thing I will say in parting
this has been fantastic and we get a lot
of comments for people who didn't even
know governor Huckabee or didn't even
know Carly Fiorina I think with this
interview with some people who maybe
didn't have in their radar you've become
there guys so if I were advising
anything and you can take it or leave it
let that you're funny you're funny
you're good let that show a little more
in the debates I think people want to
see that from you because you're good at
it
and I dig it well thank you Steven we're
doing it all the time when I when I'm on
the trail when we're doing
town halls this is what we're doing the
media doesn't show it room as we move
closer to the election we'll communicate
directly but but I'll give you something
that was just a week ago I was up in New
Hampshire did a breakfast meeting and at
the end of it they asked me about my
favorite movie my favorite movie is The
Princess Bride
oh we're going to disagree on that one
but go ahead well well then you may not
like what I'm gonna say next but a
little bit of prodding they got me to
recreate the entire scene where miracle
max is is resuscitating the Dread Pirate
Roberts and so if you want to google and
see me doing impressions of Billy
Crystal and Carol Kane and Cary Elwes
and Mandy Patinkin that happened a week
ago on New Hampshire television and if
you want to link to it my guess is
people may chuckle but I will give one
defense of myself all right a good
impression is good a bad impression is
better people laugh much more - bad
impression and I do bad impressions very
well okay so don't go there expecting
well frankly by Trump but I thought was
very well done well you just have to
play I know you don't get into attacking
anybody so I won't do it because it's
you know you just have to think okay I
will say this Stephen your show is huge
it's you well thank you very much yeah
listen I'm and I appreciate you don't
get down in the muck with politics Ted
Cruz dot-org what's what what's next for
you I guess are you looking at next
debates or there's some some big pivot
points in the campaign trail you want
people to look out for we are on the
ground every day campaigning on the
ground building a grassroots army we got
a breath a hundred thousand volunteers
we've had over 450,000 contributions of
people going to Ted Cruz org and so what
we're doing is we're gonna keep focusing
on building the team on getting
conservatives uniting we're seeing
conservatives and libertarians and
evangelicals all coming together and and
my focused every day is fighting to
defend individual liberty to defend the
constitution to bring back jobs and
growth and you know what to stand up
against the Menace of radical Islamic
terrorism because I want Mike
kids I want your kids to grow up in the
land of the free in the home of the
brave and if we allow these lunatics to
wage war against us and do nothing about
it we're risking the future of all of us
I completely agree ted cruz org thank
you so much senator people watching
click the box to go to the site and
check out his site laden with prouder if
you subscribe or click one of these
other videos to see interviews with
other interesting people and you may be
asking how do I know they're interesting
to me that's because they're qualified
beyond the youtube comment section and
they have a lot to offer the world
that's shocking I know just give them
the time of day I think you'll enjoy it